this is a production of cornell
university
hi graduates hello from ithaca
congratulations can you believe it
class of 2020 ag sciences
we are proud of you hey guys
not only are we proud of you i hope
you're proud of yourselves and the
accomplishments you have
you have made over the last four years
or two years
um we are so proud of what you've
accomplished in in your time at cornell
it's hard to believe this but you are
about to enter a new phase
you are turning from student to cornell
alum
welcome to a lifetime relationship
with people from around the world and
when it comes to ag
sciences unless you didn't know this
already
let me reiterate you now have your
forever home
guys the world needs you
i know i've had a number of you in my
classes
i've gotten to know pretty well all of
you like basically
i know you all of you and i just want to
say that your cornell training
i am totally positive has really
prepared you to take on whatever
challenges come
towards you um you know research that
you've been doing
uh working with other professors
critical thinking skills
time management all the things that you
first took with
us in our introductory course and have
taken on your additional courses so
please please do something to help us
plan it out i am i have total confidence
in all of you
we have seen you in your best and in
your worst
we have walked with you and talked with
you and supported you
and we want you to know that we have
tremendous faith in you
you are incredibly resilient
this is a moment when your resilience
has been tested
and what you have learned is that you
can do anything
be kind to yourself remember to be
flexible
and know that we're here for you
i'll end by saying i think all of you
know that i'm
uh i was born in italy and family in the
italian culture is extremely important
and i just want to say that you've all
now become part of my familia and so i i
want to say
benvenuti le familia which basically
means welcome to the family the
agricultural sciences family
the cornell family you will always be
cornelians
and always be exi majors so we would
love to
stay in touch with all of you please let
carrie and i know what
you're up to down the road when you have
families no matter where you are in the
world we'd love to hear from you
so i'll end by saying congratulations
once again to all of you and to your
families for you
that have supported you and we look
forward to seeing you
congratulations 20 20.
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu